caroline caractères aux bonjour bonjour
si d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france on lisait l'arménie
a donc annoncé hier soir une trêve avec
l'azerbaïdjan sous la médiation de la
russie il ya une reprise des combats
pourquoi il ya eu ces tensions la
reprise de ses tensions ses de ces
dernières semaines et bien parce que je
pense que l'azerbaïdjan qui est soutenu
par la turquie qui sont soutenues en
arrière-fond par les états unis
cherche à
conforter la reprise d'une partie du
haut karabakh a eu lieu dont quant à
l'automne 2020 et cherche à fait du
harcèlement et cherche en fait si on
regarde la carte des des accrochages en
tant qu'ils sont plus que des
accrochages c'est vraiment une incursion
en territoire arménien est ce qu'on sait
de situation sur place très concrète
maba on sait que en fait l'idée c'est de
couper finalement
le l'arménie du nord de l'arménie du sud
tout en évitant une intervention de
l'iran qui quand même au sud est aussi
très inquiète ce qui se passe en arménie
donc les azerbaïdjanais les azéri eux
veulent faire un corridor entre
l'azerbaïdjan et la turquie finalement
c'est ça qu'on appelle la fameuse route
dont on n'a pas décidé du sort et de la
réouverture donc on est vraiment là
quand même face j'ai entendu qu'on
parlait d'accrochage de deux petits de
d'événements militaires etc on met quand
même face à une reprise
très agressive et claire et nette de
l'azerbaïdjan donc j'espère que la trêve
qui manifestement est en train d'être
mise en place
par la russie et grâce à la russie qui
est quand même le facteur stabilisateur
dans la zone des soldats sur place deux
mille soldats russes sont sur place oui
absolument et sont en interposition faut
bien comprendre que c'est de
l'interposition c'est pas du
rétablissement de la paix c'est de
l'interposition mais c'est très très
important parce que eh bien sinon
évidemment l'un comme l'autre d'ailleurs
états sont dans un niveau de tension et
d'agressivité qui fait qu' on peut
craindre quand même que la guerre ne
reprenne et est là elle a eu quand même
des conséquences humaines assez
ravageuse quel est l'état d'esprit côté
arménien parce qu'on se souvient après
les accords finalement beaucoup ont jugé
cet accord c'est le feu catastrophique
ils réclamaient la démission du premier
ministre nicole pashinian il refuse
aussi ce cessez le feu dans la
population
je ne pense pas que ceci dit si vous
voulez la mesnie elle se sent
agressée en tant que nation là
aujourd'hui et c'est net c'est une
violation de la souveraineté
territoriale de l'arménie c'est
indiscutable
la population ben oui elle a subi cette
guerre de reconquête par l'azerbaïdjan
d'une partie du haut karabakh mais pas
de tous elle a aujourd'hui une petite
partie de ceux de ce haut karabakh elle
avait elle-même conquis dans les années
90 qui est peuplée d'arméniens qu'elle
peut rejoindre entre j'allais dire
l'arménie mainland et son son petit bout
de haut karabakh y reste c'est ce qu'on
appelle le fameux corridor de latchine
et c'est ça qui est ans en fait en jeu
aussi donc les russes l'ont interrompu
pour éviter que les choses
ne s'envenime est-ce qu'il sera rouvert
pour permettre cette continuité
territoriale
je ne sais pas mais la population est
évidemment sur les dents la population
elle elle revit de nouveau le
traumatisme de la guerre de reconquête
azéri dia bien non tiens le
positionnement l'union européenne dans
ce dossier belle position de l'union
européenne
si vous voulez c'est comme d'habitude
c'est à dire c'est complètement en
dessous des enjeux c'est sans moyens on
parle beaucoup j'ai même entendu
l'oiseau expliqué voilà c'était encore
la russie qui était à la manoeuvre etc
cela c'est pas le sujet il faut
stabiliser cette zone et il faudrait
surtout parce qu'il ya l'union
européenne il ya surtout la france et
nous sommes quand même coprésident de ce
qu'on appelle le groupe de minsk il faut
absolument revenir à un mandat sérieux
pour le groupe de minsk et la france a
tout à faire mais pour ça il faut déjà
bien
mesuré l'étiage réel de ce qui se passe
on n'est pas à des accouchements on est
vraiment là à une tentative azéri qu'il
faut absolument condamnées pour ce
qu'elle est voilà donc pour conclure
un cessez-le-feu on lisait très fragile
aujourd'hui avec crainte de nouveaux
combats dans les jours qui viennent les
mois qui viennent peut-être mais ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que c'est
pas cela on n'est pas dans un conflit
religieux on est on est au centre d'une
zone extrêmement stratégique où il ya
tout un tas de puissance qui se
disputent leur influence vous avez
l'iran vous avez l'arménie vous avez
l'azerbaïdjan vous avez la turquie vous
avez là georges et vous avez la russie
vous avez derrière les etats-unis vous
avez israël aussi qui est qui est
intervenu assez assez forte au côté des
américains n'ont donc on est dans une
espèce de tectonique des plaques et il
faut faire attention c'est pas seulement
la question du haut karabakh ou de
l'arménie en tant que tel l'arménie et
un est en fait un enjeu et un témoin
d'une zone géopolitique qui bouge qui
est en résonance avec d'autres conflits
et d'autres dossiers et sur laquelle je
pense que le devoir de notre pays
devrait être d'avoir une attitude ferme
mais très stabilisatrice avec la
puissance qui quand même contrôler les
choses et empêche qu elle ne s'envenime
qui est aujourd'hui qu'on le veuille ou
non à bruxelles voyeur qui est
aujourd'hui la russie merci beaucoup
caroline dialecte eros pour votre
éclairage ce matin dans la matinale vers
fait franc je le rappelle vous êtes
présidente de géo pragma